a day worthy
of a new attire and unlike previous
years
a new mask for mukhtar and jai and his
son they're on their way to pray at
dakar central mosque for this
very special muslim celebration but
there's a sense
of apprehension
i don't feel totally comfortable or safe
the virus is spreading
many people are ignoring restrictions
and traveling to their villages to
celebrate
the government banned public gatherings
but thousands congregate anyway
worshipers cannot enter without hand
sanitizer and a mask
in his sermon the imam warns the virus
is back
even stronger than before he advises
people to respect
barrier measures and social distancing
but inside the mosque
thousands pray shoulder to shoulder toe
to toe
with the delta variant rapidly spreading
in africa
the world health organization has warned
some government's health systems
are on the verge of collapse
under-resourced health systems are
facing dire shortages
of health workers supplies equipment
and infrastructure needed to provide
care to severely ill
covet 19 patients in senegal cases have
tripled in the last week
president maquisal is threatening to
reimpose
restrictions including closing borders
curfews and regional lockdowns there's a
sense among many senegalese that the
restrictions suggested by the government
are just too much to handle the economic
fallout of them
has badly affected the economy and so
despite the spread
of the delta variant people are going
about their daily affairs
all 22 members of india's family prepare
the meal
and jai is not ready to sacrifice a holy
ritual
because of a virus despite the risks
nicholas hawk al jazeera dakar